all right youtube let's get our skates
on so if you're not quite finished
that's totally okay i've put up these
review questions or either i i designed
these review questions on the basis of
things that i know you've encountered in
the past but especially at the start of
the year it's kind of like
yeah it's still a bit scratchy in there
however the other thing is that one of
the most important ways for you to
develop like when you come towards a
major assessment task like your ap3 is
coming up one of the ways that you can
make sure you actually learn this stuff
and it sticks in your brain
is to keep on reviewing stuff that is
just out of reach of your memory
let me say that one more time one of the
ways to make sure stuff really sticks in
your brain is to review exactly those
things that are just at the edge of your
memory because here is why think about
this there are lots of things that you
remember and lots of things you forget
how does your brain choose what to hold
on to what to retain and what to discard
because you better hope like of all the
things you see and hear and watch you
better hope that a lot of that gets
forgotten because it's not important
right if it was all there clogging up
you'd have a huge problem trying to like
work out what's important so your brain
purposely discards things that it thinks
okay this is not valuable get rid of it
okay one of the ways it knows something
is valuable is if you return to
something again and again and again over
time
think about how you learned to tie your
shoelaces
at this point you could like tie your
shoelaces i hope without even thinking
without even looking maybe while you're
having a conversation with someone now
once upon a time that was a really
sophisticated skill that you had to like
focus on really hard and it would still
be difficult to do but you did it
repeatedly not like you didn't cram it
you didn't go to like a week of
shoelace tying tutoring you just did it
steadily maybe like a couple of times a
week and it's just in there right
same deal with this right i will put
money on the table a question exactly
like one and a question like 2 abc will
appear in your hsc in about nine months
time i'll put money on the table you
want to be able to do this just without
thinking right so if you're looking at
this right now as i saw a few of you and
i'm like um it's a bit scratchy i know
some parts but other bits then this is a
sign this is a good thing to review and
to do it regularly okay
let's have a look at question one the
first thing before we get to an f dash x
is you probably want to reframe the
original f of x you want to re write it
slightly differently the x cubed is fine
but how might you write one over x in a
more helpful way any takers
yeah go ahead
x to the power of negative one fantastic
if you do that it's all in indices and i
can differentiate term by term so i hope
your next line you've got f dash written
rather than just equals because what
you're about to do is not equal to the
original line x cubed becomes
3x squared
power down power reduces by 1 and
exactly the same deal here so instead of
plus it's going to be
minus x to the
negative two you have differentiated but
as is normally the case if they handed
it to you in fractions not in index form
generally you're trying to hand it back
in much the same way so i think it would
be neat even if it's not necessary to
write it and conclude it like so are you
happy with that result yep
okay now let me get another show of
hands here
who finished 2a 2a most of you should
have got there keep your hand up for 2b
and 2c
okay about half of you thank you hands
down now just before we go on and i'm
happy for you to keep on working if you
didn't get to 2c like keep on working if
you're right but you'll often see
questions phrased like this in your
textbook in exercises in the hsc
just eyes up for a second 2c
2c is the real question that's what they
really want you to work out a and b are
just kind of there to give you a bit of
a leg up right and i really mean that
they're trying to like work out here's
the path you can take and even say part
a right you've got this function y
equals x on x minus one appearing again
and again and if you can't differentiate
it it feels like well i can't do any of
these things down here
but see how they give you or when i say
they i mean me i wrote this this morning
see how i've given you the derivative in
part a
if you can't work out the derivative
maybe you're like i've only got three
minutes left in the exam and i start
this part
you can actually use this result in part
a even if you haven't worked it out if
you know what to do in b and c just say
like right part b
given this and then off you go right so
if you ever struggle or maybe you get
the driven and you're like oh i got the
wrong derivative right use their one
right they give it to you they're trying
to actually give you a hand us teachers
we call it a scaffold like you're
building you use a scaffold to help you
okay
let's have a go at doing this dude to
make sure we're all on the right track
for y equals x on x minus 1 to find d1
dx what's the name of that rule that
we're using again
this is uh starts with a q
this is equation rule because that's a
quotient you're dividing okay so just
again using my colors here i find it
helpful to designate which is which does
it matter which is which
it does matter which is which unlike in
product rule in product or you could
make u or v whatever why does it matter
which one is which in this case
yeah go ahead let's make
one minus one deposit yeah very good
like you're actually doing division here
right and the order of division matters
uh 24 divided by 6
is not the same as 6 divided by 24 okay
so here some of you might remember you
use this
version of the quotient rule is probably
the most succinct one it's not the one
that appears on your reference sheet by
the way but i think it's just a lot
easier to write and then we're just
gonna go through here okay so help me
out what's v
x minus one what's u dash
one now even though one doesn't change
it i like to write down one because
number one it's for me to check off that
i've done all of the pieces and number
two it communicates to the person who's
reading whether it's me or a peer or
your marker or you when you're going
back to check your own solutions it
communicates to them i know what i'm
doing i'm going through step by step so
even if it doesn't change anything i
highly encourage you to write the one
u in this case is just x and then what's
v dash
it's one again so i'll just i'll pop
that in some brackets there you're happy
with that
okay on the denominator here comes v
squared is there any advantage to
expanding that denominator not really so
i'm just going to leave it i'm going to
collect my like terms on the top
x minus 1 in here
take away x so what do you get left with
after everything cancels
just that minus 1 because the x's are
going to go so minus 1 over x minus 1
or squared so we're there like i said
even if you didn't get there you can use
my result
all right part b
it says find the gradient
i've just found the derivative which is
a function you can see based on my
values of x it changes how do i find or
do you have a question or a suggestion
yeah go ahead
i got the same answer but i didn't use
the question okay what did you
the i just do the x minus one to the top
okay so
going back to something that we did up
here right you can rephrase any function
in different ways and actually this is a
big thing for later on when we passed
our review you can reframe your function
a different way and use a different rule
so what you've done
tell me if i got this right you wrote
this as x times x minus one to the
negative one yeah and this is a product
now right so you could use product rule
on it okay um thank goodness we've got
the same thing because whichever
approach you should arrive at the same
spot i would say it's probably
pretty similar the amount of work that
you probably had to do yeah because it's
not it's not neat either it's like oh
i'm gonna get fractions and all that
kind of thing but yeah i'm happy with
that it's totally fine
how do i come back to part b how do i
find the gradient using this derivative
what's the process that i do
yeah go ahead
yeah fantastic this derivative tells me
the gradient anywhere any value of x you
like i'll tell you what the gradient is
and i've got a specific one so i'm going
to write
and i encourage you to actually use some
words right don't just put equations
down and like say i hope you know what
this is going to mean actually say what
you're doing when x equals 2
d y on dx equals and then i'm going to
substitute into here right
so negative 1 on the top
two take away one or squared does that
make sense so this is not difficult to
evaluate on that denominator to take
away one is one square it you still have
one so what's your whole gradient
just negative one okay
so you can picture that right it's kind
of like sloping downward and now our
last step our real question was
i need the equation of a tangent okay so
this curve it looks very roughly like
this
it's one of these kinds of things right
so i found
and actually um in a second i'm going to
get you to open up desmos to confirm
that we've got the right thing so if you
want to open the laptop now just so it
spins in the background
we've found that the gradient at this
point is negative one so that's kind of
slanting down
like so we know it's gradient but to
find its equation there's another piece
of information i need the question
doesn't tell you though you've got to
kind of work it out what's missing
yeah very nice i know what the slope is
i know the x value because they told me
they told me i told you
right from the start but i don't i'm
missing the y value right you can see
it's like 2 comma something right so i'm
substituting x equals 2 into the
derivative now i'm going to substitute x
equals 2 into where else where do i go
now
fantastic nice one josh back to the
original function so when x equals 2
this is true
and
when x equals 2 y is equal to well let's
have a look i'm going to get 2 over
2 minus one do you see how i've
substituted it into a different thing
right
uh that's gonna be just one on the
denominator again so you just get two
over one which is
two you happy with that
i've got a coordinate now uh
two comma two
i've got a gradient so then i can
combine those to say the equation of the
tangent
can i encourage you again please
use some words
uh even little words like when or and or
something like this it actually tells me
what all of your equations mean you've
got a lot of equations on your page okay
what equation should i start off with
i've got a point two comma two i should
fill that in shouldn't i
i've got a gradient negative one so what
form of a straight line will i use
m x minus x one okay have a look at this
right i've got an x one and a y one
that's the coordinates of my point
i've got an m that's my gradient so we
call this one very original right
point gradient form of a straight line
because you're putting the point put in
the gradient let's go ahead and actually
do it
we worked out that y coordinate just
above it was
two
we already worked out the gradient up
here it's negative one and then here
comes x minus what was the x coordinate
again
two that's coincidentally the same
that is the equation but we can tidy
this up a little bit right
i'm going to do a couple of things at
the same time i'm going to expand here
and i'm also going to add 2
to both sides so it looks to me like i
get
minus x
plus 2 what's that double negative and
then i'm going to add this 2 to both
sides
yeah you okay with that so just to
finish off
minus x plus four can you go ahead into
desmos and put number one this equation
here
and could you also put the original
function that we got handed this weirdo
looking quotient and let's see what we
actually have